what is this work done to your
self-worth your self-esteem
but honestly if you don't stay down and
you don't deal with the hard [__] you
feel me ain't ain't nothing gonna change
just like you just going in circles you
repeating the same [__] over and over
again until you break it until you
really want to change you feel me and
it's like that made me like to a point
where it's like
I don't want to keep not like that but
jump in the [__] [__] or house to
house you feel me type of [__] so it
made me stay down with the with the
folks that I got right now and made me
like stronger than how I usually
would move around I guess you would say
it built me up in in a way I guess
Do You Believe In Love
oh
kinda it depends like
kind of like I would love a boyfriend
you feel me but like in the game you
can't have no boyfriend you feel me and
I had to really like really learn that